This is Maya Fishler and I'm at the home of Jean Starker Roth.
Today is October 31st, 2007 and Jean and I are going to be talking about the years
when she was raising a family here in Corvallis, her life with Kermit and that section of her life.
And you did a great job in your interview with Wade telling about how you met Kermit.
So I don't want to make you repeat that story but it is a wonderful story about how you two came together.
But I'd like to know a little bit more.
The questions that he didn't ask you are the kinds of questions that a woman has a tendency more to ask in terms of what it was about him that attracted you.
How you knew he was the right man for you at the very early days there.
Well, I had been dating a lot of boys out at the not only at Campa Deir but also in Park in Astoria at the US.
And I know and officers clubs up there and I don't know when I met Kermit we just hit it off and the first date that we had after the original date at the fraternity house.
We just talked and talked and talked and everything was just you know we agreed on a lot of things.
He was an easy person to spend time with.
That's right. And so I think that that and of course he was tall and he was good looking.
Lots of people said that he looked just like Gary Cooper.
In fact when I obtained his picture to put in my apartment in Astoria when I had people come they'd say why do you have Gary Cooper's picture in your room?
Wow that's quite a statement.
And also after we were married sometimes we go to a gas station and the gas station boys would come up and then after they put the gas in several times this happened.
They would knock on my door and they'd say did anybody ever tell you your husband looks like Gary.
Well that's quite a compliment.
So you dated for about a year before you got married?
We met in September because that was State Fair and PI which was Pacific International.
That was a big thing with extension.
Then Thanksgiving he planted his paternity pin and at Christmas we announced our engagement and we were married in June.
That's a pretty quick turnaround so it was September that you met him.
You must have been pretty sure then that he was the right man.
Yes that's right. There was never any doubt in my mind.
Well some of the things that you did together and that was for six months that helped to secure your relationship.
Well I think that we spent a lot of time with our families and I think that was very educational because from then on from the time we met he would come to Astoria and I had an apartment in a big old house.
What do I want to say?
It was a very old old house and the people that I lived with had two little girls and I think they wanted me to live there because I could occasionally babysit if they wanted to go to a late movie they knew I was home.
I could watch the girls but we stopped.
I lost my dream.
You spent a time with your family.
Yes well he would come up and they offered for him to stay in their bedroom.
A bedroom adjoining my unit.
Then the next weekend we would go to his mother's house and we would meet there.
Then the next weekend we would come down to Carvalis and he was at the fraternity and I was with my parents.
I see.
In those days you didn't live together no more you married.
Absolutely not.
But we were at one of those three places every weekend from that time on.
Your parents got to know him pretty quickly.
Yes. How did they like him?
They thought he was fine.
They liked him from the start.
Never really discussed it but I remember very distinctly saying now if you have any I'm going to marry this man if you got any objections tell me now.
I'm like you had gotten pretty bold over the years.
You've come a long way from those early days.
So he was still going to school at that time.
Yes because he had started school and do you want me to tell you a little bit about his background?
Absolutely.
Well, Kermit was raised in Monmouth because his father was supergative schools there.
And I guess that Carvalis played Monmouth in football and he played football but I didn't know him then.
And then his father wanted to get his doctorate degree.
So Kermit joined the 3C.
Well, he went to school I think one term.
And then his dad didn't have enough money to go and get a doctorate.
So Kermit joined the 3C's and he sent his money home from that so his dad could get his doctorate.
And then...
That was right after high school?
Yes.
Then his father did get his doctorate but it was during the war by then.
And he was asked to go to Portland to teach welders how to not only weld, no that's wrong.
He was asked to teach welders how to teach welders because a lot of them knew how to weld but they couldn't teach people how to weld.
So he was employed to do that to teach.
And then Kermit went into service and his father died while he was overseas.
So the Red Cross flew him home.
And I didn't know him at this point in life.
And then his mother had always taught at school and she moved to Canby and bought a house and it was a four or five bedroom house.
And she took in teachers because she was so lonely.
And that developed when we were married and then she died when we had to get a house.
We had to buy a house that fit our furniture because she had all these beds and mattresses.
Oh, did she inherit it?
Yes.
We inherited all her furniture.
You could have started a rooming house yourself.
That's right.
But the bedding and all of that was so good to give away.
So we tried to keep it.
And of course eventually we used it with all our cans.
That's a good thing.
So where was Kermit in the war?
He was on Tinian, which is a little island about a mile by a mile and a half.
Very close to...
Oh, I'll have to think about that.
I'll have to get you the name of that.
But you know it.
If you heard it, it was very much in the news.
But it was a small island.
But there were japs on it.
And they never knew when they were going to run into somebody who was hiding in that island.
But that was when he learned to scuba dive.
Because he was a mechanic repairing airplanes that had been shot down.
And so he took the plexiglass and made a mask.
And took the rubber off the tires and it had blown.
And made the back of the mask.
And he made quite a little money during that period because he would dive for shells.
And I don't know how many shoe boxes of shells when we were married.
He brought those with him.
So he took advantage of being in a tropical location?
Yes, he did.
And he always blessed the government for sending him to a warm climate because he said that he never would have survived in Europe with a cold.
He did like to be cold.
So he was with the Air Force.
But he didn't fly. He was always in mechanic.
Well, he intended to fly.
But by the time he got through his schooling, they didn't need pilots anymore.
And he had a course of very handy man and he knew how to fix anything.
So they put him in a good job for him.
But he did have to do some combat?
No, not really. It was never a shooting person.
He just worked on the airplanes.
But when they walked around the island, they were exposed to jacks sometimes.
And I know he said that he'd dug some holes to hide in if they were around.
But he wasn't in a situation where he was particularly traumatized when he came back.
He was in pretty good shape.
Well, he was in pretty good shape.
But he told me that when he came back and of course he lost his dad.
And so his mother wanted a lot of things done around the house.
And he said he didn't go out at all. He just wanted to stay home.
So he did a lot of repair work around the house that she wanted done for.
I think it was over six months that he just didn't do anything.
Yeah, he needed to make a transition.
Yes. And then when he came back to school,
he was ready to get on with his life.
And his goal when he came back to school was to get a Tomlinson commission.
And it must be a thing of the past because I asked some military men not long ago
if they knew what a Tomlinson commission was and they didn't know anything about it.
But as I understood it at the time, it was a commission given to people with proper qualifications.
That would give them a permanent place in the military,
not a reserve commission which most of the kids who go through ROTC receive.
So that was quite an honor to get that.
And then we were going to be married in June.
And he received the Tomlinson commission just in very short time, maybe made, maybe the middle of May.
Before we were to be married and he said, he never consulted me, but he just said,
I just figured you wouldn't make a very good military wife and I turned it down.
That's interesting. Now, why do you think he thought that was it the moving around part that he thought she was looking for?
I think so. And I also think that he blamed it on me a little bit.
But I think at the time he decided to get married that he wanted to be settled down, he didn't want to travel.
So I think it was a little bit of both.
That's a hard life really definitely.
So what was his major in college?
Industrial engineering.
Oh, interesting. I didn't realize that.
And he worked for a high-ster company the first year or so.
We moved after we went on our honeymoon.
Well, I don't know whether I covered this with weight or not, but we were, he was commissioned in the morning.
And he got the Thomson commission at noon. He was graduated from Oregon State and it was 107 degrees in Carvelle.
At that time they graduated from the men's gym, which is now something else, I don't know.
And they had ice, big 50-pound box of ice in all the windows.
And I remember looking at his car, he had perspired clear through all his car.
And then we were married in the evening.
Oh my goodness. That was a big day.
It was. Had you planned it that way? Did you know that the graduation was going to be a thing?
Oh, that sounds like a stressful way to do things.
After the honeymoon, why we, and that was also a little crisis because we had the van port flood at that moment.
Tell me what that is.
And so we were going to, up to quit late Quenald.
We had to get up to Washington.
And so, Kermit said, well, we were going to spend the first night in Salem.
Because we didn't want to drive very far.
And after the wedding and all the day we had.
And there was a thunderstorm that night because of the heat.
And when we drove up the highway, there were power lines coming down and flopping on the highway.
And I thought, oh, we're going to get electrocuted before we ever have a honeymoon.
But we did. We made it to Salem. Then we knew that the bridges in part, and we're all closed.
So the only way to get north was through Longview or bridge of the gods.
And so he said, which do you want to do? And I said, well, we're off on a holiday.
Let's just go to the bridge of the gods. I've never been across the bridge of the gods.
And he said, okay, so we went up there. And we came around and we got as far as.
Some place in Washington. I can't remember the name.
Good river is close to the river.
K, it was something K.
I can look on a map and find it. But anyway, we got that far.
And the town was underwater.
So then we had to turn around, go back over the bridge of the gods down to Longview and then across.
Wow. And we called that what flood, the Vanport flood?
Vanport flood. And that was a big major.
It was where a lot of people lived during the war. It was kind of low income housing.
And it all flooded near Portland.
You've never heard of that, Vanport?
I am embarrassed to say that it happened.
It's very well known, like a lot of people.
So, was it section of Portland?
Yes. It was out by Jensen Beach.
I'll look that up and read about it a little bit.
So anyway, you were going to tell me a little bit about your wedding.
Oh, yes.
Was the material in turn in there?
Sure, that's correct.
And at first I said to my parents that I don't want to be married in the Presbyterian Church
because at that time it's been remodeled since it was pretty barney.
And cold I felt.
And I just didn't want to be married there.
Well, we got to looking at the wedding list.
And of course, Kermit's family was from Madmouth.
And my family had lived here forever.
And the guest list was getting so big that that was about the only place that we could have the wedding.
So blessed my father, he decided that he could fix it.
So that morning he and I don't know who else.
I wasn't aware of it all going on.
But somebody helped him and they brought in about 50 fertries.
There were a lot of them.
And they put it all around the front of the church.
And they were out there.
And it was so hot that they, and it was in June when the new growth was on the fertries.
And so they wilted and it looked like a little ornament on each limb of the trees.
It was just beautiful.
And so it was on the inside of the church?
Yes, they brought them all in and put them up inside the church.
And as I say, all the fertries, because it was so hot, they just wilted.
And all those little new growth on it, just hung down.
And they looked like a little ornament.
It was just really quite effective.
And then we had white, one of those white flowers that you take to San Matarys in June from a Memorial Day.
Not for Santhoms, but not down.
I don't know either, but I can look it up.
I'll let you do that.
Pretend we were able to think of it before we get through.
But anyway, it was really pretty all white and then the shades of green.
Oh, yeah.
It was really quite lovely.
And people were quite impressed by it.
Yes, and so perfect for your family.
Yes, it was.
That's a nice statement.
So tell me about your dress.
Is it something that...
Well, I made my dress.
You know, in those days, there were the bridal stores that there are now.
And I wanted to wear my mother's wedding dress, but it was too small.
My mother was a very petite lady when she was married.
But she had a lot of lace on her dress and also on the veil.
So I took the lace and put some sheer yoke on my dress.
And the lace was from her wedding dress.
So it was quite a sentimental affair.
But I made it because I was a home economist and I sewed.
And there were patterns and sewing books to use.
It worked out just fine.
And then her veil had been kind of eaten through the airs with different, I suppose, balls or something.
I don't know.
And anyway, I used all the lace from her veil around the edge of my veil.
So I thought that was quite nice.
Yeah, it sounds very touching.
Was it a large group?
Was it your family or were there friends and community members too?
Well, there weren't too many because there was my father's sister and her husband.
And then my grandmother was...
My father's mother was alive at that time.
And her wish was that she lived to see me married.
And she got her wish.
She came in a wheelchair.
And she couldn't see very well.
But we had a nice conversation.
And during our honeymoon, she died.
And so we had to come home from our honeymoon to go to her funeral.
And I was like, wow, wonderful that she got her wish.
Yes.
So there's so much planning and such that goes into weddings these days.
It seems like it's just a huge endeavor.
Did you have a big build up to it?
Well, no.
I think in those days it wasn't a three day affair like it is now.
So we just...
Well, as I say, we were pretty busy all day.
But we just had the wedding and then reception.
And people didn't stay long at that reception.
It was too hot.
But we had cake.
I think we just had cake and punch.
There at the church.
That sounds just right because then you could get out and get on your way.
Yes.
So now they do a breakfast after the wedding and all that stuff.
Dinner beforehand.
Oh, yeah.
My daughter went to a wedding not so long ago.
It was in Hawaii.
They had a big groom's dinner.
Yes, my folks did a groom's dinner the night before.
And we had a lot of the fraternity boys.
And some of the family, but there were only just those few people.
I don't think my grandmother came to that because she was too frail.
But we did have...
And they gave it because her mother was in...
She lived in Canvy.
So it wasn't convenient for her to do it.
And those days we didn't go to restaurants.
It was all done in your home.
Sure.
I've got more of a family event.
Well, you know we only had just one or two restaurants in Carvalas.
Customs in and out.
The Gables, that was about it.
The Gables was an original.
Interesting.
Have any of your...
Did either of your daughters use your dress as a wedding dress?
No.
They never did.
They wanted their own.
Do you still have that dress?
Yes, I do.
I hope you'll have a picture of you and your dress.
It won't fit now.
I don't mean a curve picture.
But I do have a picture.
Good.
Wonderful.
So you went off and did your honeymoon and then he ended up in a first job in Portland.
And how did he get that job with Heister?
Well, I think through the college in those days we had placement people.
I know I was placed in a job by a placement person on the campus.
And I presume that's how he got his job and he worked for Heister for...
We lived there.
We lived in an apartment, a very small apartment, for a few months.
Her mother wanted to do three things before she died.
And I'll try to remember what they were.
She wanted to go down to see her other son Norman, who lived in California.
She wanted to fly in an airplane.
What was the third thing she wanted to do?
Well, she did all three anyway, whatever they were.
It may come to you too.
And so she said, why don't you and Kermit live in my house while I go do these things?
Because she spent probably a month, maybe more down in California.
And she had a garden.
She was a great gardener.
Of course, can be soil is wonderful for gardens.
And so we stayed at the house and took care of the garden.
And I did a lot of canning for her and got things, you know, made use of what was in the garden.
And then she came home.
And I had an offer, I think maybe I told Wade this, I had an offer to go down to the dowels.
And do a...
Sometimes I have trouble with getting the right words out.
I was judging a fair.
So I said to her, wouldn't you like to go with me?
That'd be a nice trip for you.
And I'm just going for the day.
And she said, oh, she'd love to.
Well, she went with me.
And I judged pillow slips among them.
And broader pillow slips among many other things.
And I gave first prize to the white embroidered pillow slips.
Because a lot of the women had done multi-colored ones.
And they were pretty bad.
Excuse me.
Hello? Yes?
Yes, Rebecca, how are you this morning?
Well, I'm fine, Rebecca.
But I have a lady sitting here now that's doing an interview with me.
So I really can't talk.
Oh, good.
Well, now when are you in a week from Friday?
Okay.
Well, would you put a little tickler on your counter to call me when you get home so that we can...
I can come down and talk with you.
Okay.
Thanks.
Oh, we had a good time, didn't we?
I did.
Okay.
Bye.
Sorry.
It's kind of right.
Can you give the prize to the white pillow slips?
Yes.
So anyway, there was quite some discussion, apparently, about this judge who was doing this.
And she sat in the corner and listened to her new daughter-in-law being criticized.
She could hardly wait to get in the car and tell me that he's women, that's it.
And she was just laughing and she just thought that was the funniest thing.
They could get that excited about their real-of-lips.
She had quite a sense of humor and she used it often.
She just had a great sense of humor.
We got along just great.
Well, it's a shame that you didn't get to spend more time with her.
Yes, I would.
And then I suppose we better put in something about how she died because it wasn't more than a couple of months.
I'd forgotten when she died, but she didn't last more than a couple of months after she came home.
And we got a call when we were in Portland.
We had moved from the house where we lived while she was away.
And we got in our department in Portland.
We lived where the Safeway is now in Lloyd Center.
And we got a call one morning about 530 or 6.
And the landlady's, you know, telephones were hard to get right after the war.
And she had no telephone in her house.
And we had no telephone in our house in our apartment.
But the landlady called and she tapped on our door and she said,
your mother has had a heart attack and you need to go.
And so we just dressed and left.
And we got there.
She had the heart attack and gotten up and tried to make it over to the neighbors,
but had fallen in her garden.
And the neighbors had found her early in the morning, fortunately.
And so they got her back into the house and in bed.
And of course we got there and called the doctor.
And you know what we know about heart now is just like night and day.
Because we didn't know the minutes where seconds were important at that time.
And the doctors at that era made house calls.
So the doctor came to the house and of course by that time, you know,
she was, had quite a lot of problems.
Well, she lasted about two or three days.
I remember, Kermit went back to her apartment to clean out the refrigerator
and get things squared away because we just left and bring some clothes for us to wear.
And so when, well, he was gone to Portland to get those things taken care of.
She had another attack.
And I was feeding her some apple sauce because I had made some from her own apples.
And she said, oh, it smells so good.
I just would like to have a taste.
And so I said, well, fine, I'll fix you some.
And I was feeding her.
And all of a sudden she just, just died.
And so when Kermit came home about the time that that happened.
And he immediately called the doctor and he said, well, she's gone.
Sorry.
Hello.
Hi there.
How are you?
Good.
But I'm with a lady here that I need to, she's doing an interview with me.
And I don't have much time to talk, unfortunately.
Where are you now?
Okay.
Well, I'll call you tonight.
I mailed the package to Micah today about the coat.
Yeah, so he'll get it in a couple of days.
Good.
Well, I said I took all the things off of the batches.
And then I sent it to the cleaners.
So it's all ready to go.
All right.
Well, I'll try and call you around five o'clock work.
Okay.
I'll give you a call.
I'm sorry.
That was my grandson.
Quite all right.
So you were saying that Kermit got there just as she asked away.
Yes.
And I didn't know anything about death.
And he held her tongue down.
And it was pretty awful.
So then we had to call his brother in California.
And he came up and then we divided all the stuff.
And that's how we got all the furniture.
Because they didn't want the furniture.
They'd been married for a number of years.
And he was the oldest brother.
And Kermit was the youngest.
So they said, you just take all the furniture.
So that's what we did.
So do you think you said she had some of you wishes of things she wanted to do before you died?
Do you think she had a sense that she was?
I think she knew that.
And I really think that Kermit sensed that he was not going to live very long.
Really?
Because he was so, always so insistent that I know everything about our business.
And so, and both his parents had died of heart attack.
Of heart attack.
Yeah.
His father fell off of, he was milking a cow and fell off the stool and died.
So, you know, he had bad genes.
Yeah, that's true.
That means a lot.
Huh.
But she was a delightful person while you knew her.
And did Kermit have that same fun sense of humor as she had?
I don't think it was quite as broad as her sense of humor.
But she got a big kick out of life.
So, it was nice to know her briefly.
Yeah.
So, there you were in the big city of Portland.
Was it a pretty happening town at the time?
Oh, yes.
I think that I really enjoyed Portland.
I didn't want to move back to Kermit Palace when we finally made that decision.
But Kermit thought it was the thing to do.
We had two children by then.
And he thought it was the thing to do.
And my dad was putting a lot of pressure on him to come back and start a plywood plant.
Oh, interesting.
And of course, Kermit had the industrial engineering training.
So, there were ten men who put their money together and built the plywood plant.
And Kermit designed it and was in charge of it because the rest of the men all had other jobs.
So, he did that for three or four years.
Don't remember just how long.
But then the plywood market went kaput.
And so, they sold it to somebody.
I can't remember.
So then he went into partnership with a man, Gordon Larson.
And that's, you know, Beverly Larson, who runs the O'Mill School.
Well, it was her father that was in partnership with Kermit.
And my dad was sort of putting up the money for this mill.
Gordon had had a mill out, well, at the Y in Pholomath, he was on the wall porch side.
I don't know.
It wasn't very far up that road.
He had always had a sawmill.
But they decided they built it down here at 53rd and reservoir road.
And so, Kermit designed that mill.
And then they built it and ran it for, I would say maybe eight or nine years.
And then they had a, I wouldn't say a, well, they disagreed on just a little bit about how it should be run.
And so Kermit said he'd like to buy him out.
Gordon didn't have the money to buy him out.
So Kermit did buy the mill out.
And then Gordon died probably maybe six months after that.
That was all settled.
Because of course they had to divide up all the timberland and everything.
Oh, I see.
They had property.
They went with the mill.
They bought a lot of timberland in order to have timber in the wintertime when they couldn't log other places.
They bought timberland that could be logged in the wintertime.
So that was very fortunate that we got all that done before he died.
Yes, that would have been a mess.
I think I'd have a hard attack too as I remember it.
You could check with them about that, but I think that he did.
So that mill is not there anymore, is it?
No, it isn't.
It's where they started to run sheep.
Yeah, I know there's a little organic meat there.
They couldn't do it because it was annexed.
Oh.
I ran the property for a number of years after my husband died.
I rented it out to various people who ran the mill.
And then timber prices weren't very good.
And the last people that owned it, it was just ready to not be run anymore.
And so one day they were putting in the water pipe down reservoir road
and then it came into the fairgrounds.
And they wanted some place to dump the dirt.
And so I said, well, dump it in the pond because I just assumed fill in those ponds.
Well, it seemed as though that was not the thing to do because there are rules about filling ponds I found out.
Well, one day I spent, I don't know how long on the telephone.
It was all one afternoon and into the next day talking to governmental agencies.
And finally, I got a hold of some, I don't remember which one.
But they said, oh, Mrs. Roth, we don't talk to owners.
We just talk to lawyers.
And that was the living end.
I just decided I wasn't going to have anything to do with that.
So my, I was mopping to my son about it.
And he said, oh, mom, you shouldn't have that stress.
I said, I'll take over running it.
So anyway, he tried to run it for, I don't know, four or five years.
And he was in California and it was just too much.
So he finally sold it.
And that's when they started to run the goats.
And then they found out they couldn't run the goats because it was in it.
He had annexed it.
And so now it's...
It's in the city limits.
Yeah, it's in the city limits.
That's interesting.
And it's very odd because soon after can got through, sold it.
Now, they're, you know, they put in all that lovely area in front of the fairgrounds
and they've got the dirt over ready and they're going to run the street.
They're going to go up over the railroad and they're going to do that right away.
Oh, I didn't realize that.
That's interesting.
So bad at the city.
You know one thing after another.
So he, so current was, as long as we're talking about his career,
I can ask you the rest of my questions about, about his career.
So he then stayed at that mill till, I know it was.
He wanted himself in 67 then.
And then did he stay with the mill?
All the rest of his life?
Yes.
Yes, he shut it down after he'd run it 12 years.
And we didn't do anything with it.
I guess he...
I can't remember whether he rented it to anybody or not.
But he played the stock market and he was very sharp about it.
He would get up in the morning and look at all the listings in the paper.
And he made a lot of money on the stock market because he just had a feel for it.
And one time we bought Fuji Photo Stock.
And we made a lot of money on that because it was just when it was starting to come into the United States.
So he said, I think we should take a trip.
And I said, well, we made our money on Fuji Photo.
I think we should go to Japan.
And so we did.
And that was real fun.
We had a lovely, lovely trip.
So was that when you had all four children?
Did you take children with you on the trip?
Yes, we did.
Wow.
Well, I guess we can skip to that.
I want to get back to a couple more questions about his progression through his career too.
But I'd love to hear about the Japan trip since we're there.
Well, we got a lady to stay with...
In the meantime, my mother had passed away.
And we got a lady to stay with the children.
But she had to also feed my father because after my mother died,
the course that day, I said, will stay for dinner.
And he just kept coming.
He kept coming.
That lasted 15 years.
He had a regular dinner invitation.
Well, he didn't have an invitation, but he came.
And he didn't leave at the table.
And at first, he lived just through the woods between Jackson and Van Buren.
But then later, he moved out on to Timmion edition out on 53rd Street.
And then by that time, Kim was learning to drive.
And so she'd go out and get him and bring him in because he wasn't driving by that time.
So he just always came.
That's a nice thing.
That's good.
So you had a woman who stayed in the house and...
And she had to feed him too.
So care of things there.
And then the rest of you packed off to Asia.
Yes, we did.
It was a very extravagant trip at that time.
Oh, it was.
Well, we've stopped over in Fiji going.
And then we had a couple of days there.
And then we went to Japan.
And then on the way back, we stopped at Porobora.
Wow.
How long was the trip all together?
I think we were gone three weeks.
That was a pretty long trip.
Yes.
And that was your first time out of the country, right?
We've been to Hawaii a couple of times.
So you've done some flying.
Yes, because we took all the family to Hawaii a couple of times.
So was it...
Was Kermit more of a traveler since he'd done his stint there during the war?
He really enjoyed the trip to Japan.
He just thought he didn't have any desire to go to Europe at all.
I think he'd heard too many tales during the war of hardships in Europe with the military.
But he really...
I don't know why, but he just thought the Japan was great.
Interesting.
And...
What's...
What's over?
So having been in the Second World War and over in that part of the World War,
was it hard for him to embrace the Japanese?
Did he feel any prejudice against them?
No, it didn't seem to be.
He didn't seem to have any feelings about the Japanese.
And we were there during...
What do they call that?
When you have the world?
It was...
Not the world's fair.
World's fair.
That's what it was.
And of course, we were so tall that the Japanese...
We'd hold our hands out like this and the Japanese would get under our arms and then they wanted their pictures taken.
Because we were so tall.
Oh, that sounds wonderful.
What an experience for your children to be able to see that.
Well, they showed...
We showed them the pictures, of course, when we got home, but they didn't go...
So the children didn't go home?
No, no, no, no.
Okay, okay.
No, he...
The babysitter stayed and took care of them and...
They took care of everybody.
I see.
They did.
I hope it's that all together.
Yeah.
Well, I want to ask you some more about some of the other travels, too, but...
So we don't get too off course here.
I'm going to take us back to where we were when you were talking.
I just wanted to finish up learning a little bit about Kermit's career, because you've been talking about that.
And what I wondered was when it was that he started getting involved in property management,
how we move from being an industrial engineer to...
Yes.
...through the lumber business and then into...
That's quite a transition there.
Yes, it was.
Well, I told you that my mother had died there, and I had inherited the by-mark property through the...
My mother's part when she died.
And so my dad had given me that property in exchange for some property that he had.
And that's a 10-21 real estate exchange.
And that's how that came about.
I did that.
That's probably he's more known for that in the United States than for his forestry.
Are you familiar with that?
Well, when I first started looking, researching your family a little bit before I started, I looked and I did find that...
...that many references on the internet to TJ Starker have to do with that real estate judgment.
Yes, that was decided and then has been sort of the standard then from then on.
Yes.
And so we inherited that and then we bought several...
When he was working with the stock market, we bought several pieces of property.
And in turn did some 10-31 exchanges with that and we always traded up.
And so we just...
You know, that was our income.
Because we didn't have anything.
We had to have some flow.
But when Kermit died, there was not much property that was giving me any real secure monthly money flow.
And so that's when I started doing the real estate thing.
Because I traded some of the timber land that was left over from the mill.
I traded that for real estate.
More usable.
And that I would really like to have some emphasis put on that because when my father died, he left me having.
In fact, in his well it says to my daughter Jean, I leave nothing.
His whole point in establishing his timber was to create a starker forest.
What would you say?
Like a Thea or a...
Yes.
And he didn't want it broken up.
So he didn't.
And everybody thinks I got some money from him and that's how I got started.
But that's not the way it was.
He wanted all that to be kept within the structure of the business.
That's right.
Interesting.
And you know, I could be bitter.
But it's...
I don't know what I did with that piece of paper.
I have two things that I think I'd like to put in this because that's what I lived by.
And I wrote that out.
Well, all of a sudden I go out to the kitchen before you leave and see.
Because I wrote those sayings down.
One is something about...
It's worded better than I can worded, but it's something about if you have an acid in a container,
it sometimes eats it the container that it's in.
And there's another one about there.
And I think that's very true.
I could be really bitter.
And I could be very upset with my nephews.
They had nothing to do with it.
It was all my dad's object to leave that as a unit.
And he didn't really appreciate women either.
He didn't like the fact that women were in the forestry school.
And he didn't really like my sister-in-law got interested in the timber business.
And he really didn't like that either.
He was a German.
Yeah.
The oldest son.
Yeah, that's a long-standing tradition of patriarchy.
Yeah, that's right.
Well, you did very well.
I probably by...
German's hard work in the stock market and buying things at the right time and that kind of thing.
And does the Roth property services business still exist?
Oh, yes.
That's what I do.
Three times a week I work at that.
I have a bookkeeper that comes and keeps track of things.
And I manage the properties.
And I have four major properties that I'm leaving to.
And I have one to each one of my children.
So how did you learn how to do all that real estate business?
I don't know.
I think it was by Osmosis from hearing my dad speak about it.
I think I just absorbed the way it was supposed to be done.
His talk at the dinner table was always about business.
And I think I must have just sort of absorbed it.
Did you increment work together in the early years when you were...
Absolutely.
Yeah, absolutely.
I remember one time we owned up that property down the corner of...
It's where that painting pottery painting place is.
Downtown.
And we owned that building at one time.
And the real estate man, I remember this so vividly,
he called up and he said, did we want to sell it?
And Kermit put down the phone and he said, do we want to sell that?
Because there was a lot of agitation at the time that they were going to change downtown.
And the Madison Avenue Task Force was in starting and they were going to do big things.
And of course the guy that's chairman of the Madison Avenue Task Force is a very good friend of ours and still friend.
But I didn't always agree with what they were doing.
And so I said to Kermit, you know,
I think we're going to be charged a lot for doing makeover there.
And I said, what do they want to give us for it?
And so the realtor said, well, what do you take for it?
And we don't, we don't held it a year or so.
And I said, well, 50,000 more than we want to pay for it.
And he said, my buyers will take it.
So, 10 minute conversation.
I thought that that was a pretty good way to make 50,000 bucks.
Well, so you, the two of you were sort of a business team.
Yes, we'd always kind of saw eye to eye on how we did it.
So forth, we never had any discussions.
We just talk about it.
That was it.
Go on from there.
So did he ever regret leaving me off being an industrial engineer?
No, I don't think so.
No, I think it was very much, I think he really enjoyed the business aspect of it.
He thinks so.
Sounds like he was a natural at that.
Yes.
Yeah, I'm sure he did.
So you had your first two children there in Portland?
Yes.
And then we moved down here.
And we had a house down on 10th and Adams.
Right by the railroad.
Pacific through.
Sure.
I don't know where that is.
Yeah, about word.
Yes, yes.
Yeah, where it was right there.
Where we had our, we bought the house because it had enough bedrooms for us to put the furniture.
And then my dad was developing Cedarhurst, which is the corner of 35th and Harrison.
And he had, I think it's 32 acres in there.
And he developed that with a division of Badbeer and Jackson.
And he gave us a hunk of property down on Jackson Street because he'd given my brother a piece of that area between Badbeer and Jackson.
But clear at the end of where the dairy barns were.
And of course they lived at the last house out on Harrison.
They built that when I was in high school.
So that's where we lived.
So after we moved back to Curvellis, why he gave Curvell and I this piece at the end of Jackson.
And Curvellis just took a year off and built that house.
And he built it with the help of one carpenter.
And I think he only subcontracted.
He did the wiring.
So he subcontracted the heating and the water.
Seems to me there was something else.
He did all the rest of it himself because he was capable of doing that.
And I backed primed all that siding.
I would go out there after the children got up from their naps in the afternoon.
And I'd go out and they'd play in the yard.
Well, I was painting.
So we did it together but it mostly curmed.
That's impressive.
Is that house still standing?
Yes. The Kines lived there.
Yes, in fact it was written up in the paper recently.
Yes.
I remember seeing your name in that article.
And how long did you live in that house then?
We lived there 35 years.
So all the way through your childhood memory?
Yes, and he died from that house.
And I lived there six years after he died.
But you know it was a seven bedroom house.
And it was a little big for one lady.
And so when my last one married, I knew she wanted to be married from that house.
She's a very sentimental girl.
And so as soon as she was married then I thought,
boy, it's time to take care of Jean.
I then built this house.
I see.
I built this house.
But Kathy in the meantime had gotten an architectural degree.
And so she designed the house pretty much for me.
And then built her.
Wow, wonderful.
So I really supervised all the building of this house.
Do you like building?
Yes, I do.
And then later I built the house at Newport.
So I built two houses.
That's impressive.
I helped my husband and I built our house.
And I always think I would never do that again.
But some people really enjoy it.
Oh, I did.
I just thoroughly enjoyed it.
Yeah.
So many decisions to make.
Oh, yeah.
But I loved it.
I thought it was great.
Wonderful.
Good.
So I'm trying to envision your life here in Corvallis with four children all pretty close to the same ages.
Well, they were actually ten years apart because the first three were two years apart.
And we waited four years and then had the next one.
But still you had your hands full.
Yes, yes, I did.
I was busy with the children.
Had you stopped working before you had children?
Yes, I did.
But I did a lot of not only volunteering, but I did some teaching at the high school with what do they call that?
Well, it's where you teach certain courses to adults.
I don't know what they call that now.
They used to be night school.
Yeah, something like that.
But now it does have a note in the name you're right.
Yeah, and I don't know what that is.
But I taught Pendleton Jackets were very popular.
And so I taught a class on Pendleton Jackets.
And sewing them.
Oh, huh.
Mm-hmm.
Well, in Pendleton Jacket had a lot of the principles of sewing.
You know, the pockets and the...
But it wasn't really complicated.
Really?
But it had a lot of principles of sewing.
So I found that very much fun to teach people the basics.
So what kind of things did your family do?
Were you able to do some things as a group with all six of you?
Or was that really too many kids to take little trips with and things like that?
Oh, no.
We used to take the kids fishing every Sunday out at Quartz Creek.
And then Bruce and Betty had a pond out...
Well, it was out towards...
Or was that out?
We went out to the Y and turned towards Wallport and what would we call that?
I don't know.
I weigh 34.
Yeah.
And then they had some timberland out there that they had a pond on.
And there was a group of us that were quite...
It was the Jim Hallons, the RT Rises, the Budcrolls.
And...
Well, I guess that was at Bruce and Betty.
And us.
And we all worked together usually on Memorial Day, Fourth of July.
What's the other holiday?
Labor Day.
Yeah.
I haven't taken a guess.
Usually went out to the pond.
And then, Kirby and I always took the kids and we went to...
We owned some property out...
Big elk.
And we went out there, crawdading.
Oh.
I got a great picture for you to put in the book on the crawdads.
Oh, that sounds like fun.
And then we would ask somebody to come and eat crawdads.
We had crawdads feed.
Big pile of crawdads.
And then we...
As I say, we took the kids fishing up Quartz Creek.
And then finally we got a boat.
And by then, the Rises had a place at Triangle Lake.
And we would go down there sometimes with our boat and...
And the kids watered ski.
Oh, that's fun.
That was when they were older maybe.
Yes.
So, Kermit enjoyed his family life, it sounds like.
Oh, yeah. He was a family man.
I'll tell you.
When he had the mill, he would sometimes go and get equipment from other mills that were maybe no longer in service.
And he would say when he left, well, I may not be back tonight because we might have trouble loading or, you know, doing all this.
Almost always, he'd be home by midnight.
Uh-huh.
He'd never stayed over any less.
He just wanted to be there in the family.
Yeah, he wanted to be home with the family.
I never had any concerns about him full-handering.
That's a good thing.
Help, he was definitely a family man.
How about summer vacations?
Did you guys ever take any trips?
Not really as summer vacations, but we, of course, had the place up the McKinsey, which was really nice because he had been in the three seas up there, which I told you about it.
And so we had that in common, too, because I taught school up there.
And so when we came to having a second home or the second, whatever, it wasn't really a home.
It was a mobile, no.
What do you call those?
Not a mobile.
Yeah, I guess a mobile home.
Like a trailer?
Uh-huh.
Yeah, it was a trailer-like place.
And so when we bought the property to put the trailer on, it was up the McKinsey, because we'd been up there a lot, because we liked that area.
So he had done trail building when he was there in the CCC?
Yes.
Interesting.
So that made for a good weekend getaway, probably.
I guess it was.
It was great place and the kids loved it.
And they loved to fish.
And we had three great fishing holes on that property.
And we liked it so well that after we'd had the mobile home for a while, it was a single wide.
And we decided that we liked it well enough, and we wanted a fireplace, because then it was cozy, and we could use it in the wintertime.
So we had him haul away that one, bring up a double wide.
And I had that for a number of years after Kermit died.
But all of a sudden there was a crack house moved in next door, and the people who owned that were from California, and they rented it out.
And they brought up a lot of antiques and put in it.
And it was just a gorgeous place.
They rented it out, and it was a crack house, and the people who had it needed wood for their fireplace, and they burned up all of the antiques.
And I thought they'll probably be over here next.
And I thought this is no place for me, so I sold it.
And it just killed me to sell it.
It was 40 miles from any fire or police help.
Sure.
There was no place for a single woman.
Yeah, that's understandable.
So I had to give it up, and I still hate it that we had to give that up.
Well, sounds like you had lots of good years from it.
No.
I'm not that fun out there.
I just have good memories.
Yeah.
That's a good thing, too.
So you mentioned having your holidays with Bruce and Betty, and I realized I've never asked you what the transition was from when Bruce was sort of a nerdy kid who sat in
the medias, and it's like a video time.
When did you start to get close to him?
Well, I think that Betty had a lot to do with that because she met Bruce because I had invited her to a summer party when we were in high school.
When she was going to college here, and her father was an ROTC professor.
He was a military man.
And so Bruce offered to take her home after the snook.
And so they were soon married, and then we did a lot of things together.
We used to camp up at Spirit Lake where we had spent our Bruce and I had spent our childhood.
And so we did a lot of things together, and then after Bruce died, Betty and I traveled a lot together.
So she brought the two of you closer together?
So she brought him out of it.
He became a lot more. After he was in the military, I think he became a lot more social.
Yeah, that's right because you had told me that you saw each other a lot in San Francisco too.
Yes.
Yes, that's right.
Well, I'd love to hear a little bit about your children.
Okay. Now we're early.
Well, I guess we should start early.
Well, Ken's the oldest.
And he was born in Portland.
And he was a good baby.
He was a real...
We had him.
I don't know. Did we tell you?
Did we talk about the house that we had in Portland?
Not in great detail, no.
Well, I told you that the first house was this apartment in the safe way.
Where the safe way is now in the Lloyd Center.
Well, then we moved over to the house that Ken was born from.
It was the Westminster Presbyterian Church Mance.
And it was a four-story house.
It had a basement, a main floor, a four-bedroom, second floor, and a floor attic.
And so we called it the Roth Hotel because everybody came to see the...
The came to Portland, stayed with us.
Oh, your friends.
Well, Ken was born from there.
And then Craig came along.
And that was when we...
Craig was about six months old when we moved to Curve Alice.
And the house that we had there was all these floors.
And it had six plugins.
Well, three of them, I think, were in the kitchen or maybe four.
I would gas slides.
A sink that was way down here.
And I was pregnant with Craig.
And so, Kermit took out the kitchen and put in what they called a Youngstown...
Youngstown sink.
And it was a sink with train boards, all one piece.
And so we put it up so I could do dishes.
And then we had Craig.
And the thing that I remember about Ken when he was a little kid,
he had a rabbit that he loved, stuffed rabbit with stuffed.
And we had a backyard that we fenced.
And so one day he was missing.
The lady who had been helping me with Craig had left the gate open.
Well, I was just beside myself.
So we lived at Wider, I think it was.
Anyway, it was two blocks down to Broadway.
And here he was walking along with it holding the ears of the rabbit,
just wandering around having a good time.
I was just friends.
He was a very adventurous child.
Then Craig came along and he was born with no bicep,
or no tricep, and he's left arm.
They think I had interunion and polio.
That was when polio was so becoming something that was everybody had to have a shot.
So Craig was never athletic.
Ken was always very athletic.
But Craig was, when he'd ride a tricycle, he could do a tricycle pretty well,
and he seemed to bicycles.
He couldn't balance because he couldn't get that arm up.
So when he was in, we moved to Kervales,
and when he was about,
I would say maybe six weeks or so in Dachindee Garden.
The doctor that we had here in Kervales said,
I want you to go down to San Francisco and go to Stanford Medical School
and see what they can do for him.
Because he'd come in and he's a little face.
He'd fallen off his bicycle, you know, and his face was all scarred up.
He just didn't have any balance.
So we took him down there.
The story that I'd love to tell about Craig is,
my folks took us down to go, we were going to fly down to San Francisco
and it was fogged in, and so we had to go on down and go by rail.
Well, Kermit and I were just beside ourselves.
This was a very nerve-wracking experience for both of us to be taking this child down to the hospital.
We didn't know what was going to be the results of this.
So because my father was a T-totler,
we didn't ever drink at home.
We always called it juice.
And so we went in to have some juice in the railroad car.
And we got a coke for Craig.
And the bartender there put a cherry in it.
And so when he came, he had the operation and came out of the anesthesia.
And he was his legs and his arms were just thrashing.
And he yelled out, just an allowed voice, I want a cherry in my.
We were never able to tell my parents that that's what happened.
Oh, cute.
And I think that's such a hot ass store.
And the little things that were just in his subconscious at that time.
So anyway, we got through that.
And then Kathy was born.
And we were, we just expected another boy.
You know, we were just thrilled to have this daughter.
And then Kim was born four years later.
And the girls were really quite good seamstresses.
I suppose that I taught them a lot of those things.
And they earned, they were blue ribbon winners for four H,
for their dresses that they made.
I think it was Kathy went on to state fair, got a blue ribbon.
They were really good seamstresses.
Still, they don't do much.
I think Kathy does more than Kim.
But they were very active in four H.
So were you still involved in four H?
Yes, and later when I was on the four H,
I was a trustee for the four H.
Steve board that they had.
And was, my dad was very instrumental in obtaining the property for four H,
of the four H camp that's over near Salem.
Right.
And I was very active in that for a long time.
Were you a four H leader as well when the children were younger?
Yes.
And I think I told you that Irma Seymour was my four H leader.
I think we talked about that.
So you worked with him.
So I've always been active in four H.
And still am to a certain extent.
We support the swimming pool at the camp.
I read that.
So interesting.
Were the boys in four H as well?
No, they were both Eagle Scouts.
And in fact that conversation was about that because my great grandson is now in Scouting.
Wow.
And so I took all the Scouts always were red flannel jackets.
And I happened to remember that in the cupboard out there I had craigs of Scouts from his Scouting.
Wow.
And so I gave it to my great-grandchild.
I took all the things off of it and handed it to the cleaners.
Oh no.
It's going down there.
That's fun.
Yeah.
That's funny.
I think I read somewhere that Kermit was involved too with the boys Scouting.
Yes.
With the, I don't know what they call that.
The headquarters are in Eugene for this area.
And he was active in that management of that.
At the regional level.
I don't know what they call them trustees or what they call them.
Anyway, he was active in that for quite a while.
That was wonderful.
So as a home economist you think that you were more prepared than other women going into this whole child-bearing thing to be able to be-
I suppose so.
You know, because we learned a lot of child education and what we were supposed to do and how we were supposed to handle problems and that sort of thing.
Yeah.
I think probably.
Did you continue to do the kind of things that you had been teaching other women to do with in terms of preserving food and-
Well, I've always worked with the extension service to a certain extent.
You know, even as a volunteer.
And I think that I did.
I followed through on a lot of that.
What do you think was your strength as a mother?
Do you think there was something that you were in the family that everybody depended on you for?
Cooking, I think.
I think a good meal.
That's a very important point.
Well, and I think that we cooked healthy meals because I had learned that.
You know, we always had meat and probably potatoes of some sort or rice or starch of some sort.
And vegetables and salad.
My husband always wanted to salad because when he was in the service he didn't have any greens at all.
And I think we mentioned that he wanted lettuce when his brother came to visit him.
And he always wanted greens.
So we always had balanced meals and we always sat down to eat together.
And of course later my dad ate with us.
That's something that I would not do again because I don't think it was fair to my children.
When you sit down to eat your evening meal the kids want to talk about their days.
And my dad wanted to sort of, he was the conversationalist and he wanted to tell us about his day.
And I don't think it was fair to my children to do that.
But you know, you did what you had to do at the time.
They accommodated.
But it's true, it's not all that common out.
They have a regular meal that in itself is that.
But as a result, Kermit came home every day for lunch from the meal because you know it was just a short distance.
And that was our quiet time together.
The two of you.
Because we hear and often, well, sometimes not quite often, he would bring salesman home for lunch.
And he said, the thing to do was for the salesman to take him out, you know, try to win his favor.
Yeah.
And he'd say, oh no, let's go home.
Geno cook something.
And so I think that that was our time together and it was also, I always had something in the pantry like a can of chicken or I could do a zillion things with chicken.
You know, it was chicken salad, chicken soup, chicken dumplings.
You know, there were lots of things I could do on the spur of the moment to.
So and sometimes he'd just call 1130 and say, can I bring someone so home and I'd say, oh sure, you know.
And when you say can of chicken, was that something that you had canned?
No, no, it wasn't.
No, I didn't want anything to do with those chickens.
Yeah.
I wanted them prepared.
That's one of the luxuries we have now.
So tell me if you're getting tired or are you still doing all right?
No, I'm doing fine, but I suppose we ought to quit around three.
All right.
I'll move through this.
I was, I'm almost in the same age range as your children, so I'm thinking about the era when you were raising kids and thinking about how it was such an era of change and more permissiveness and that sort of thing from.
Yes.
Certainly from the era when you had been raised and you had been raised in such a strict way anyway.
Was that a tough transition for you to make to figure out how to set rules and discipline for your kids?
Well, I think that there was a lot of discipline.
You don't do this because your grandfather was this way.
And the other thing that I remember vividly, and I don't remember whether I told way this or not, but one day the teacher called me up when Kim was in school.
And she said, we're talking about letting the girls wear pants to school.
And what did I think about it?
And I said, makes a lot of sense to me.
They turned their little bottoms upside down on all the playground.
Well, yeah, on the playground thing.
I said, makes a lot of sense to me.
And so that's when children, because otherwise I see pictures of my kids in their grade school era.
And they always had dresses on.
And then all of a sudden the pants became popular.
Yeah, I can remember when you have to change out of our school clothes into our play clothes.
Yes, that's right.
And those play clothes usually were pants.
Yeah, that did change at a certain point.
But you got through those teenage years without too much.
No, my girls didn't date.
Ken dated in college, but I don't remember that.
Well, he did date when he was a senior.
But I don't remember that we had to any concerns about that.
Good.
They were pretty, you know, they had learned.
I used to tell him, don't misbehave because somebody knows you and somebody is going to towel on you.
I say the same thing. It's the beauty of living in a small town.
Were there particular stages of childhood that you enjoyed more than others?
Like did you love that stage when they were just little and...
Yes, I did.
And I think that I probably enjoyed the girls when they were all maybe six to twelve or something like that.
I really liked that age.
They were old enough to be talk to and sensible.
You know, you could kind of guide them through that period.
I really enjoyed that part of it, I think.
How about the boys?
The boys were always so active in scouting.
I think Kermit did a lot of the parenting at that age with the boys because he would take and camping with the scouts.
And he would arrange to have them go and meet with other people to get their badges.
I think he did a lot of the parenting with the boys.
It's interesting.
He'd take them to the mill and lots of times he'd come home if he had to go to Eugene or Portland for a part or something.
He would come by and grab one of the boys and take them.
And that was very helpful to me because that gave me a little freedom.
And I remember one time he was coming back from Eugene and he and Craig were singing.
And he wasn't watching this pedometer and he got stuck.
So the cop said something about what were they doing?
And Craig piped up and says, oh, Danny and I were singing!
And the cop said, you know, if more dads would do that, we'd be a lot better off.
You can go.
So we did the rest of it.
That was a little story.
That was interesting.
But then either of your boys went into that field, into what products or...
No, or a tree or anything.
No, Ken started out in forestry.
And then he would go out and have field trips and he'd get poison oak.
And he came back one day and he told us he said, forestry isn't for me.
And he didn't go to the woods.
And by that time I think he was seeing the writing on the wall too about that it was going to go that way.
So he changed and went into business.
And neither of the girls was ever interested.
Oh no, girls, in that air, I don't see.
And he was starting to come into being...
I think they just had one or two girls in the forestry school.
And my dad didn't approve of that.
He still had a big influence on your family.
Oh yes, he surely did.
Who this could be?
Oh, I'm stiff from sitting there.
We've been here for a little bit.
I'm just a package.
I always bring the doorbell.
I didn't know what you know that he's there.
So your father was sounds like he was very influential in your life, even after your children were born.
Oh yes, I think he was.
And he really broiled the roost because of his eating with us.
Yeah, I would say that.
And the children probably had that sense.
Like you say that there were eyes all over the town.
Yes.
He was going to hear about it.
Oh, he was on the school board.
You know, he knew everything that was going on.
Did I tell you the story about him?
They were trying to raise money for taxes.
But the school board was.
And the man came to Lyons Club.
And my dad was very prominent in the Lyons Club.
And he was the one who started, I don't know, you've been reading these articles that Ken Munford's been putting in.
Yeah.
And he was one of the principals who started the Avery.
Right.
And well, anyway, what was I going to say about that?
Well, he was in so many, oh, I know.
So the super kind of schools, I think it was Dr. Van Lohn.
And he came to the Lyons Club and made a plea for them to all vote for the increase in school property taxes.
And my dad got up and he said, well, I'd feel more inclined to vote for this.
He said, you can keep going because the other one will catch you.
Yeah.
He said, my grandson was just kicked out of the first grade.
And something about one of the other kids.
Ken was kicked out of the first grade because he was a big boy and had a little bitty teacher for a teacher.
And she sent a note home and said that he was misbehaving.
And what was I going to do about it?
And so I went down to see about it and I said, what does he do?
And she said, well, he won't keep his feet under the desk.
And she said, I tried putting him out in the hall.
And he just sat out there and visited with everybody and enjoyed himself.
So she said, I guess that's not the way to handle it.
And so I looked at her and I said, where does Ken sit?
And she said there.
And I said, well, you know, if you go down to the sixth grade and get a desk, the fitting, you could probably, you probably wouldn't put his feet out in the hall.
Oh, she said, I never thought about that.
So anyway, my dad told this story at the Lions Club and the old Dr. Van Lone came up afterwards and he said,
T.J., when you've got something like that, would you just come and tell me privately?
But you know, he had a lot of clout because he wrote all these letters to the editor and had an opinion on everything.
And so the kids were pretty well.
You know, if they didn't see Pop, they knew somebody, some of these friends would see them.
So they were pretty well.
Did I tell you that I used to worry?
He would have articles in the paper about how many acres of timberlandy owned and something like this.
I think, oh, why do you put it in the paper?
It was about the time of the Lindbergh kidnapping and I was so worried that somebody, you know,
I think you were an easy target.
Oh, yeah.
And I worried about that a lot.
But nothing ever happened.
That's a good thing.
And how about your mom? Was she involved with your children?
She was a good babysitter.
And you know, she had that cart that was the golf cart.
And she would come by in the afternoon and take the kids in the golf cart.
And she had to go down to the grocery store.
She'd take them with her.
Oh, it was fun.
Yeah. So she was very much involved with the children.
I think she was more in jail with Bonn and Bart because Bruce and Betty traveled more than we did.
And she often kept them for several weeks at a time.
And then I would kind of take them for periods of time because I knew she needed to break.
Because, you know, she was getting older.
And so the boys came down and made a lot.
So logging roads with the trucks that my husband made.
When he worked at, he worked at another business.
I forgot the name of it in Portland.
But it was during the war, beginning of the war.
And the V, not World War II, but World War.
Was it Vietnam? It was next.
Probably Vietnam, yeah.
And he worked at this die casting company.
And he worked at the dog trucks for kids size.
And the employees were allowed to take parts home that were not perfect.
And so, Kermit would bring them home.
And he made, I don't know, six or eight log trucks.
And these were big log trucks. They were about like that.
And paint them.
And they had to buy the tires.
And they had little tires like that.
But he would, I think, Kathy still has those log trucks.
I think that he made six or eight of those.
And he would convert them to flat beds or dump trucks.
He would make little, the dump trucks would, he sort of changed the configuration of some of them.
But the Bonn and Bart and Ken and Craig would make logging roads all over the place.
They loved to do that.
And they would play.
And it was really no trouble for me to keep them sometimes to give my mother a rest.
Sure, yeah. Were they about the same age as your boys?
Yes, well, there was Craig.
Let's see, Bonn, then Kermit came into the family, then Ken, then Bart, then Craig, and then Kathy.
And then Kim came along later.
So the boys were pretty well.
Yeah, so they were pretty much the same age.
Did you guys do holidays and things with their family?
Oh, yes.
Christmas and...
Yeah, we always had things giving in Christmas with them.
Oh, that sounds like fun.
I think you said when you were talking to Wade about Christmas that your dad was a little shocked that your holidays were more extravagant than the ones that you had had when you were growing.
Yes.
Oh, yeah, we gave too much to the children.
And I'm saying the same thing about mine.
Every generation probably feels that way.
Yeah.
Oh, well.
But it's so much fun to indulge them.
I did have some questions about traveling.
Do you have any just 503 now?
Could I ask you a little bit more about traveling?
I talked a little bit about your trip that the two of you took to Japan and that kind of thing.
And you didn't take any trips with the children during that time when they were growing up.
Oh, yes.
We did.
We took them to Hawaii several times.
But we didn't ever take them farther than that.
I don't think.
Why is it a big trip for a family of six?
Yes.
Yes, it was.
It was quite a... quite a... jaunt.
And what island did you go to when you went there?
I think we went to the big island because we went up to the volcano.
We thought that was educational.
Yes.
Yeah.
And then Ken would sometimes come by himself or Craig when they were a little bit older.
But we'd take the two girls and then we took the two girls to Australia.
But this was when the boys were older and Ken was married and Craig was...
Or was Craig.
I guess maybe he was married too when we took the girls to Australia.
What inspired a trip to Australia?
How did you choose that?
Well, no, what made us go to Australia?
I think we just started wanting to go...
Kermit always wanted to go that direction.
He never wanted to go to Europe.
I think we just thought that was a good place to go.
And I think Kathy wanted to go.
She wanted to go.
It was the time they were building the music center.
We're like opera houses.
And I think that she was very interested in the way that was constructed.
Yeah, that's an amazing thing.
Because Kermit and she spent one whole day of our trip photographing it and walking around it and going through it.
And she did a report for class at Oregon State and got some credits for doing all of that.
So she knew from the very beginning that she wanted to be an architect.
Yes, she did.
She loves architecture.
Wonderful.
What does your younger daughter do?
She wanted to be a nurse.
But she met her husband instead.
And so then she took education.
Oh, well...
She's been a school teacher and a substitute teacher.
That's wonderful.
Well, I guess she never was a regular teacher because when they were married, she had twins quite early in her married life.
And so I think she just did substituting.
But she loves teaching.
So you've stayed very close with your children.
Sounds like.
Oh, yeah.
As adults, you're all still there.
You know, they're here now.
Kermit and Wald are here.
That's right because they're building the courtyard.
Courtyard.
Are you involved with that project?
Well, somewhat.
Yeah.
When they get in a bind, I help them out.
Not only financially, but otherwise too sometimes.
Because you have that experience with dealing with contractors and real estate things.
Have you worked with any of your other children on construction projects or real estate projects?
No.
They're all kids very handy.
Like he's dad.
He's very...
He can do anything.
And Craig's pretty handy.
But he's...
His recreation consists of hunting and fishing.
Is that something they used to do with their dad too? The hunting?
Oh, yes.
They always got their deer.
We had some forest lands out here.
And we reserved that for family hunting.
And so there were other people shooting around them.
Good idea.
And so they've always hunted and fished.
But Ken doesn't do that much, but Craig does a lot too much.
Well, I think it's admirable that you're still so close with everybody.
Well, I think we're as close as...
You know, we talk probably every week, at least.
Sometimes, you know, if there's something going on, we talk every other day.
You know, just like Gary called me.
You know, he...
Well, he wants, but he calls me every once in a while.
That's my grandson.
Your grandson.
So, it's kind of nice.
Yeah, absolutely.
And it sounds like you must have been the kind of mother that everybody was sort of comfortable with.
Well, I guess they were.
Because they share, you know, they keep in touch.
Uh-huh.
That's a nice thing to be able to say.
Yeah.
Good.
Well, we could take a break here, as you'd like.
All right.
Next time we'll go on to talking a little bit about more about your community work.
And we can, you know, we can start back in these days when you were involved with your kids and trying to work around.
Yeah, I had a couple of things here about when we lived over on Jackson Street,
but we had a...
a holly...
a whole row of holly trees.
Uh-huh.
And so every Christmas we trimmed the holly trees, and then the girls would put them...
put the clippings in the wheelbarrow, and they'd go up and down Jackson Street and ask anybody if they wanted holly for Christmas.
Uh-huh.
And they just gave it to them, you know.
Oh, sweet.
So that was kind of nice.
Uh-huh.
Did you have some other holiday traditions that were different or leftover from your growing up years?
I don't know that we...
we certainly had food that was very traditional, but uh...
we always had turkey and always had dressing, and uh...
I could tell you some funny stories about that.
And sew it pudding.
Uh-huh.
That was carrot pudding, steam pudding.
And uh...
Interesting.
And we usually had boiled onions, little pearl onions.
Uh-huh.
And uh...
cranberry ice.
You always had that.
Uh-huh.
As an ice cream?
What is cranberry ice that is...
Oh, no, it's a...
it's an ice that you eat with meat.
Oh, you know.
It's a pear to that.
Oh, very fancy dinner has the clearier palate, you know.
So the shape...
Was it shaped in balls or...?
No, we always just made it, uh...
you know, with a beater.
And then we scoop it out and put it in a little sherbet dish.
Oh.
And that was served with all the hot things.
With your turkey.
Sweet potatoes, candy, sweet potatoes, mashed potatoes and gravy.
That's standard menu always.
Still is.
Except for the sew it pudding, I haven't heard of anybody making sew it pudding in a very long time.
Well, we always made that carrot pudding, but it's made with sew it.
Uh-huh.
And uh...
What do they call the stuff you put on the top of it?
You know, you make it with sugar and egg and...
Meringue?
What?
No.
Why can't I think of the name?
I guess I haven't thought of it since last year.
Meringue and egg.
And it's not Meringue.
Well, I can't think of what it is now that we've always put on top of it.
I can still see my mother sitting in front of the fireplace before we had beaters.
Uh-huh.
And she would whip that stuff, took forever to me.
Not marshmallow.
No.
Oh.
Did we talk about the Burlington family and Uncle Gus?
No, but I'd love to hear about them.
You didn't...
Well, we got to talk about...
You talked about...
I know you talked to Wade about Uncle Gus bringing you raisins as a kid.
Yeah, well, that's what we've done that thing.
Um...
Well, I just...
The date that...
I think I was going to look up some dates for you and Kermit died at 59 and he died in 1979.
Okay.
Had he been ill at all before that?
Well, not to...
You know, he always was not just...
Well, we didn't...
I think that we always thought that he was fragile, but, you know, but didn't realize what it was.
You know, in those days, heart things were...
It was very different then.
Yeah.
Well, we made a big strides in heart.
Well, I guess that's all I had on my little...
Sometimes I wake up in the middle of the night and I think, oh, we need to talk about this.
Yes.
That's a good thing.
I'm glad you took notes.
And if you think about it, things definitely bring them in.
Yeah.
So, Kermit died just of a sudden heart attack?
Yes.
He was just fine and we had come back from a trip to Mexico and he went down.
He was building a photography studio in the basement.
He thought he'd take up photography as kind of an avocation.
And he came upstairs and he said, are you ready to go and do errands downtown?
And I said, yeah, I'm ready just as soon as I finish this note.
I said, I'm writing thank yous to the people that been nice to us.
In Mexico and all of a sudden I looked over and he was laid out on the bed.
And I said, Kermit, what's the matter?
And he just kind of looked at me, you know.
And I went over and I felt his forehead and it was just sweaty.
And I said, what is the matter?
I said, I think I better call the doctor.
He said, yes, I guess so.
And I think he knew what he had.
But I didn't at the time.
And so I called the doctor and he said, get him to the hospital, get him to the hospital.
And so I said, can you walk out to the car and he said he thought he could.
So he did and then he threw up and you know, I ran to get a pan so that we could,
if he threw up again, we could didn't need to stop and we got him out to the hospital.
And some little man came up.
I didn't know him from Adam.
And I think he thought that he, that I knew who he was.
He apparently was the heart doctor.
And I didn't know him from Adam and as all he said to me, he says, your husband's a very sick man.
And I thought, well, what's he sick about, you know.
I said, well, can I see him?
And he said, yeah, go ahead and see him.
But I still didn't know they had a heart attack.
And so he lived that day.
And then the next day they took him to Portland, OHSU.
And I was, February and it was, I see, oh, there was this much ice on the streets everywhere.
And I didn't think we'd ever make it uphill hill.
But the ambulance, I don't know if they had chains or not, but they made it up the hill.
And I knew he was very sick when they, when they made everybody get out of the elevator and let us in.
I knew that there was something bad going on.
So he just lived that night and he was gone the next day.
So my life changed.
Yeah.
I don't think I really said I'm changed.
You never know what the future brings, so you better live every day.
Yeah. Well, it sounds like he did live.
He sounds like he enjoyed his life.
Oh, he did. He enjoyed every day.
Yeah.
Yeah. And lots of good hobbies and travel and stuff.
It's still too short.
Hmm. Well, thank you for telling me about that.
Yeah, I'm eager to talk to you too about, I try to imagine you stepping into
a car and taking over there at the property business and that sort of thing at that point.
I guess you had been so involved that it wasn't that big of a lead.
No, it wasn't because I think he had a premonition all the time that he would, that I would outlive him because my family had, you know, sort of an older reputation of whatever.
And his family had always died suddenly.
And so he was pretty insistent that I be aware of everything that was going on and financial things.
Yeah.
We always talked over every deal.
Uh-huh.
So I just went on from there.
I just picked right up and kept moving with it.
Oh, huh.
Good.
Well, next time I'd like to talk more about not only your community activism.
I have said many times that hate is like an asset that does as much damage to the vessel in which it is stored as to the object on which it is poured.
The other one is Gem of the Day when the tide of life turns against you and the current rent current upsets your boat.
Don't waste tears on what might have been just lie on your back and float.
That's wonderful.
Those are the two things that I look at.
Yep, words to live by.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
Thank you for keeping us.
Keep all that stuff there handy.
Uh-huh.